so und nächstes jahr kommt schon
und herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video in dem ich heute nicht nur die
super sieg und settings challenge
endlich mal richtig spielen möchte
nein heute wird auch der gewinner des
ipads bekannt gegeben ich hab den
ausgelost wird erkläre ich euch jetzt
mal kurz und im laufe des videos wird er
bekannt gegeben das funktioniert
folgendermaßen also ich habe mir gerade
eben kommentare durchgelesen
ich sage auch ganz ehrlich dass ich es
nicht geschafft habe alle kommentare
durchzulesen
weil das einfach nicht geht ist ein 4000
stück leute so viel zeit habe ich nicht
in kanaan dann würde ich heute nacht
wahrscheinlich gar nicht schlafen und
wir werden die augen aus dem kopf von
4.000 kommentare sind halt ist ein über
4000 zucker ich weiß nicht wie es genau
sind und da werden hat man die tausende
angezeigt so es sind über 4000
kommentare 4 teilen von 4.300 so um den
dreh
das kann man einfach nicht lesen also
freue mich in einem abend ohne komplett
durchzudrehen deswegen hoffe ich
verstehe ich jetzt die alle lesen konnte
ich habe auch viele gelesen und ich habe
meine elf favoriten aus diesen vielen
die ich gelesen hab ausgewählt und habe
dann diese 11 durchnummerierten mit
zahlen von eins bis elf und dann bin ich
in ein random number generator zum euro
in dieses gegangen und habe mir eine
nummer generieren lassen und die erste
nummer die rauskam war dann die nummer
des gewinners so der gewinner steht auch
jetzt schon fest und wie gesagt er wird
im laufe des tages bekannt geben auch
spiele heute die super six exchange und
ob das heißt wenn ich jetzt einmal
runter fallen dann werden all die super
six settings rein geballert ich spiele
heute ohne ob tief ein weil das habe ich
herausgefunden ob die fein das problem
war
ich hab gerade eben schon mal einen test
gemacht dadurch das texture pack
rausgenommen ob tief eindringen lassen
da hatte ich wieder diesen blöden
extreme dann habe ich jetzt das texture
pack drin gelassen ob die fein raus
genommen und tests haben ergeben dass es
so funktioniert
na ja auf jeden fall wissen wir wenn ich
jetzt runter falle werden die ein
geballert die settings ich drücke hat
die ganze zeit noch r
was mein zoom hotkeys wird besser bei
optikern kann man suchen und diese taste
war bei mir hat er das drücke ich
einfach die ganze zeit so routinemäßig
etwas passiert natürlich nichts war
nicht installiert ist okay aber zum
beispiel wir recht sauber ohne jumper
bisher gefällt mir gut
ja ich weiß auch nicht jetzt gar keine
ahnung was mich erwarten wird bei den
super secret settings aber jetzt sehen
wir als ok option und zeigt was ist das
denn also man sieht es ja als ob man
sieht dass sie sogar halbwegs aber es
ist ja für pixel ok nächstes rhein alles
klar
wahrscheinlich wir so das ding hier oder
was das ist noch mal kurz drin ich
möchte einmal probieren ob hier ein
bisschen voran kommen wir damit ich mag
das ding mich irgendwie cool wie das
aussieht alter das welche wie auf drogen
minecraft lsd genommen oder so nein okay
jetzt herunter nächste setting 18 okay
das sieht so gar nichts normal alles
klappt so sollte man ein bisschen
spielen können vielleicht mal gab dieses
modul findet dass wenn ich die ganze in
diesem verein ist natürlich super dass
sie gut aus hierbei waren parameter ich
bin gerade fast von meiner sprinttest
abgerutscht okay man sieht wie die world
borders da draußen animiert linie sind
da es hat ein bisschen komischen touch
auf jeden fall die super sieg
das ist ein bisschen komisch aus sowieso
bisschen an wie ein weichzeichner aber
es geht man sieht halbwegs was würde ich
sagen und einer finde ich aber fast das
jump'n'run so zeigt exakt hier und da
war er finde ich einfach gleich ich
würde es mal packen ehrlich gesagt ja so
ist ja wir die kiste nehme alles wird
schön einpacken hier sagt zeigt dass da
auch noch und so weiter weiter weiter
weiter weiter
heute wartet er mit dem finnischen und
ich war wieder runter nächste setting
sei jetzt aber die drogen drin leute die
drogen wirken
es ist ja so jonas die kiste wartest du
auf einmal gucken
als erstes wäre hoch alter ich bin
richtig auf droge was ist das für ein
lsd jetzt darunter sprechen oder wie
auch kaum steuern
alter schwede hat gereicht kann man hier
und jetzt niemals komm ich darüber doch
doch jetzt wird kann er sich unter falle
aber nein ich hab es gibt packt und hier
in papas auch sehr schön es läuft es
läuft eigentlich sogar halbwegs so jetzt
das ding hier ist natürlich wieder
bisschen tricky glaube ich oder wie hoch
es läuft überraschend gut jetzt nachdem
wir diese blockaden hatten ok
runtergefallen nächste setting war ja ok
jetzt ist feierabend
jetzt ist halt echt feierabend leute
upside down wirklich aber wenn jetzt
irgendwie laufe ja ich glaub ich
versuche mir loszulaufen
ich weis bewusst oben ich glaube so oder
block drauf ist dahin
leute ich hab 0 orientierung ja so
glaube ich fast jan eis alter sind
wiesen jedoch auf ok altersstufe dass
ich als zuschauer das ist richtig so zu
spielen dahin ja jetzt haben uns das
nächste reihen für steve nash da alles
klar immerhin nicht upside down und da
würde ich sagen machen im deathmatch
einfach auch für jeden kill immerhin ein
weiteres rein
okay er hat auch das golden finde ich
gut man lieber moritz so alles easy und
ready wir haben wir zumindest man es ist
eine gute sache
und jetzt wird gefeiert leider kein ob
tief ein
ich habe auch keine chance zu sehen was
für den klub mit die leute wir haben
weil unterscheide mal die akkus von
irgendwas anderem hier so 997 khimki
gemacht wo ist setting das setting ist
verschwunden
das hatte ist verschwunden okay dann
muss ich wieder ein klatschen ja alles
gleich haben wir fernsehen oder wie
leute wie sie das denn aus ganz ehrlich
wie sieht das denn aus ja ob oder seiner
karriere des 2 ok ich hab' keine chance
das mitlaufen ok ich muss das ist ein
gegner das bein und block logistics
verschwinden von selbst
aber ich hoffe jetzt mal ein tnt ihr
denn es geht natürlich nicht an dass ich
nicht meine settings reim machen weil
ich eigentlich einfach um müsste lola
lebt hat er liegt richtig hartes gesehen
referent auch ziemlich hat glaube ich
wenn ihr zu sagen okay heißt neues
setting rein also die settings
ausgegangen ein alter was ort kein
zuwachs die wir gerade drin dann würde
ich mal sagen okay es kommt ein neuer
auf drogen bin ich auch noch mal der
beste pvp auf dem server wird aber damit
tatsächlich gilt heißt nächste super six
etting und zack alles darf ich wieder im
fernsehen
da ist hier ist das erste deutsche
fernsehen mit der tagesschau
heute in der tagesschau spiel ein
bisschen schlampig nicht dauern
jetzt bin ich dann sagen wir das auch
neues rein und wisst ihr was ich spiele
es ein bisschen damit hier
mögest du warst nicht mehr so viel leben
glaube ich aber da wie still dabei
diagramm an ich vermisse das zoomen ich
kann nicht suchen
mit optimalen weil ich klasse s mit opti
find ich hab kein abfall der tat direkt
hinter mir
die lucky uralter springwater neid die
tu die wollen mich oh gott oh gott nein
die machen machen wir nicht jetzt will
ich aber auch mal machen
mainz liegt vor mir war irgendwas drin
egal alles mitnehmen so jetzt warte ich
am gemacht okay das heißt wieder eine
ein neues setting das hat man ordentlich
und jetzt niemand dass wir mal ein
wunderbarer jetzt wieder hinten rüber
und versuchen kids machen wir beide noch
zwei leben hier immer gespannt die
feuerwehr so aussieht
ja komm ich dran ja er brennt er brennt
alter weg wie das feuer aus die kripo
und haben geholt ich habe geholt nice
wie gewinnen die runde fast mit den
settings das gibt's doch nicht so und
nächstes rein da kommt schon was ist das
denn wie soll man zu spielen ich habe
wirklich keine ahnung wo der gegner ist
er brennt okay er brennt so viel weiß
ich schon mal
es hätte geht raus hatte geht raus alles
klar
wir müssen ein neues reim machen
geschieht wird nicht so egal
das sieht aus wie so ein trauriger ware
zusammenschnitt hier gerade und richtig
wenig geben leute wir sind einfach kurz
davor die superzicke zeitiges challenge
zu gewinnen wer richtig wenig lebens
sage ich euch mit hits bekommen wird
gebrannt tnt alles drin und da kriegt
man schwer tut mit gleichem weg wohnt
jetzt ist und wie sieht's aus bei die
erste noch genug leben und werk
wegzustecken ergab dass der gattin
geblieben bin ich sage du bist jetzt
nicht weil auch nicht mehr rex überhaupt
nicht einfach mal ja und das war kein
hit da war keiner glaube ich man sieht
natürlich schlecht weil alles schwarz
und weiß ist und es ist ein one hit wie
vorhergesagt im sony gewonnen wenn sich
auch gefallen hat würde ich sagen lassen
leichter schatten die kommentare ob ich
das noch mal machen soll
weil die settings war natürlich
andererseits sind mir richtig gut
gefallen muss ich sagen spaß gemacht
glückwunsch an den gewinner der müssen
auch noch auflösen ist und zwar hat da
bist du in glückliche gewinner des ipad
mit 16 gb der liebe artifex place
herzlichen glückwunsch
ja das was mir passt